welcome back now as a former culture
secretary herself Nadine Doris has a
thing or two to say about our biggest
broadcasters so you can imagine she
really has not been holding back about
this whole Philip Schofield Scandal
we've been watching unful out of this
morning over the last week or so now
she's been calling this matter an abuse
of authority power and Trust she's
calling for a probe into complaints made
to ITV about Schofield and having
appeared herself as a guest on this
morning last year she says she's seen
firsthand how quite rude and
unprofessional the former presenter
behaves so who better to ask than the
lady at South the MP and uh talk to the
host leaving Doris from talk to his very
own Friday night with Nadine uh they did
let's start very simply then should this
morning survive
we've got some connection issues that
Indian if you're just one of my unmute
yourself because we've got a lot of
questions to ask you about broadcasting
about this money you got us there should
this morning survive
I didn't actually mute myself but there
you go and so yeah I don't think it can
survive it's a story which isn't going
anywhere and it's
um it's one which is unfailing and
moving on a daily basis I think as I
think there have been illegal hurdles
when it first broke and I think those
hurdles have been overcome now so I
think it's not going away I think it's
one that's going to continue to go to
continue to grow and I just don't think
it can survive in its present format and
I think it was Diane Nelms who said it
that you know who's the original
um editor of the show but it's it really
just needs to go now it's also a stale
format actually it's been here for a
very long time with the same presenters
but there is so much which is
questionable about the entire culture
within this morning as a program and we
see this happen a lot in organizations
not just in television companies or
broadcasting organizations it happens in
organizations like the NHS and major
companies a culture grows
it becomes toxic and it is protected by
those who are aware of the culture until
something gives and it's usually a
whistleblower or something happens to
kind of bully the lid off and that's
what's happened on this morning I spoke
to people who've worked on the program
and people have worked on the program
over a number of years and they all tell
the same story
and so can it survive your substantive
question
and possibly I don't know you know I
don't have a a crystal ball but I don't
think it should survive I think it needs
to be taken over by a safe Pair of Hands
a pair of hands at the public know that
they can trust because they've been lied
to there's been duplicity and an almost
a what they cover up and I think the new
safe power of hands while they spend
time thinking about what should be doing
with our midday
new spot on magazine spots should we
continue as it is so I should survive
maybe I mean I get your point about this
happens in other types of Industries you
cited there the NHS it happens at
corporations toxicity investigations
that sort of thing but those are
fundamentally more substantial and
important things you know hospitals and
health care and companies this is just a
TV show isn't it I mean I'm not
detracting from what schofield's done I
think it's abhorrent I'm not detracting
for the experience of the boy at the
center of the law which we must always
keep in mind uh as well and keep him
anonymous and the rest of it but it's
just a TV show is it not why why do we
care about this why are we talking about
this why does it matter to the public
honestly it's not that question almost
makes my blood boil because we have in
society men who use their positions of
authority and power and trust and use
those positions to
behave in a way which is inappropriate
and unacceptable I'm not going to quote
others within the same industry within
entertainment we know within the
entertainment industry there are serious
problems with individuals
but I think now we're at a point when
you're following on from me too and
other things that have happened I think
now we're at a point when I I when
Behavior which has been identified and
which has been covered up within a
culture which has protected that
behavior and in a culture which is toxic
and hugely inappropriate it has to be
called out it's not just a television
program it's it's a a situation where
not good things have happened and I'm
afraid that ITV both the executives the
editor and other people on that program
must have known and that's all because
of that because of that because of that
cover-up that I'm afraid they have to be
held accountable ITV is a public free
tour public service broadcaster it has
responsibilities both ethical and moral
and standards that it has to uphold just
because it's a television program
doesn't mean it can absolve itself of
those responsibilities we all have
responsibilities when we know that
inappropriate behavior has taken place
to call it out and to make sure that
it's dealt with in a way that sets an
example that others can see so that they
don't follow and they don't allow that
behavior to Fester within their
organization I think that's a strong
argument I think setting the right tone
the example I want to come back to you
on the public service broadcasting side
of it in the regulation Point as well
but I want to pick you up on your first
point there about you know my question
making your blood ball because your
answer in a sense makes my blood boil
because you said it was about me too or
it could be uh construed as having
something to do with that and this is a
man that is bullying and yes Phillip
Schofield is a man that is bullying in a
situation but I am always first to point
out when there is gender-based issues
going on toxicity and misogyny but in
this sense I think it is irrespective of
gender it is just an ego it's just
bullying it's toxicity and we see this
across many Industries and it's not
always uh men's fault there are women
bullies in this industry and I have
encountered them and I'm sure you have
too
I you know I knew to television so I
don't work in Industry as you do Rosanna
or for as long as you have so I haven't
come across that many people all I can
say is that the women I've come across
on talk have been absolutely fabulous
empowering women that I've loved working
with so I haven't encountered it myself
yet but you know if I did I would call
it out in the same way I would if I
encountered it in a month in the same
way I called it out in Phillip Schofield
now I'm afraid I haven't I haven't heard
women mentioned in the capacity of any
form of abuse or behavior that we've
seen amongst other men in the
entertainment industry going back over a
number of years now and you know we do
have to very carefully legally so I'm
not going to cite other other
individuals and other high-profile
stories that we all know about but the
point here is there is a man Philip
Schofield who has himself resigned from
they stepped away from his role and and
was further going to work with ITV in
another role until ITV removed him who
has behaved in a way which has been
highly inappropriate and that behavior
has been covered up by Executives at ITV
who absolutely must have known about it
because everybody else did and so I find
it impossible that they didn't the
editor of the program knew about it and
complaints were made and those
complaints were not act upon and if they
were asked on they weren't acted Upon A
Norway which got to the truth of the
situation and and exposed what was
happening
that you know every now and then
something will happen which which needs
to reset people's thoughts and behaviors
and their approach to to their work and
how we conduct ourselves whether it's in
television or it's in offices or the or
wherever it is and I'm afraid this is
one of those instances it is one of
those instances I'm in agreement with
you there um we must obviously State the
executives have denied a lot of the
allegations levied against them a lot of
these details are still ongoing and
emerging and we have of course had
statement upon statement for my TV uh
denying this as we've had a statement
from Schofield as well but some some
astonishing Revelations just in the last
two hours uh Nadine this one about the
payoff the executives allegedly knew
this is a an article in the mail online
this evening uh Executives knew about a
payoff that was given to the young man
as he was moved over to loose women and
the other
um a bit of detail that we've got here
are more pictures of the anonymized
young man that I want to come to you
specifically on giving you a former
secretary is that the executives are
going to be hauled up before a committee
a government committee next week to talk
about this as part of the sort of Media
bill review that's ongoing so talk to us
a little bit about why you think the
government should be intervening here
because a lot of Americans look at
British TV and say government intervenes
too much
well because ITB is a public service
broadcaster and therefore it will play a
huge part in the media bill which is a
bill I launched and introduced when I
was Secretary of State
um the media built impacts ITV in a way
which is
um which is
favorable to Public Service broadcasters
so I'm afraid it's absolutely right and
proper that they should go before the um
dcms cut slack committee absolutely
right that they should do not think that
there's a some of the public will see a
bit of an irony in seeing uh members of
Westminster debating sleaze and
corruption in the TV industry oh yeah I
get that yeah I totally get that yeah
yeah I'd be a reason why I'm standing
down the next election yes you have
stood down and we it is worth restating
and of course you're part of the talk TV
family now um just before we let you get
on with your evening a what a family is
the producers the same way yes it is a
family uh let's just uh none of the uh
allegations levied I will say that we've
talked about relate to this network at
all
um but let me just ask you a little bit
about your experience when you're on
this morning what was it like and what
kind of impression did you get of Holly
as well
so I spent highly absolutely lovely and
she was she was delight and I can't
remember how many times I've been on the
program but it was the last time I was
on when Holly wasn't there and um
someone was starting to Joe was standing
in for Holly and what I saw actually
made me so you can see the picture on
the screen at the moment
um gosh I can't remember the other beats
that presented it her name's Josie
Gibson Josie Gibson she was on I think
it was love Island and while she was
holding that very script in her hand and
uh the camera was on me he landed over
and started jabbing at that script like
this in her hand
possibly of seeing what he was pointing
to his face was like thunder it was
incredibly aggressive and she just sat
there holding the script as he was
bashing it with his hands while the
camera was on me and it actually made me
feel incredibly uncomfortable and yeah I
mean that that was it was he was
unpleasant you know and I know I've
heard from so many people that he you
know didn't know the names of anybody on
the production teams even people who'd
worked there for years many years with
him that he was that he was rude I mean
I think Eamonn Holmes has given his own
um account of what working with Philip
Schofield is like and obviously he's far
more authoritative than I am I only saw
him you know for the occasions and I was
sat in front of him but I always found
Holly an absolute Delight
what I'm disappointed about is as the
story has moved on it is actually
unbelievable that Holly did not know
what was taking place and although I
found it I find her Delight passing on a
personal level I think there must is
some degree of that cover-up
encompassing Holly as well and I think
that's incredibly disappointing because
I think she's an amazing role model for
women particularly women who want to
work in the television industry her
career has been just impeccable and to
this point I'm afraid a bit like you
know in the morning show when
um the the host took down other people
with him I think Phillip Schofield might
be people he's been working with on this
morning which I think is sad because I
think the holidays are professional and
you know which I've always found her
lovely
up but it could be the case that she
didn't know what was going on because
everybody else did he wasn't as close to
Phillip Schofield we will be talking a
lot more about this toxicity nests and
what people knew but Nadine it's up to
you me everyone else in Industry
obviously to continue to be nice to not
be bullied uh and to engender a better
work environment Nadine Doris it's been
great having your insights on this this
evening
cheers Nadine thank you